than alarming new evidence of a major
coveted Spike Across America ahead of
the holidays Omicron is now the dominant
strain in this country making up 73
percent of new cases so in the last
seven days there have been nearly 930
000 new coveted cases yikes more than
204 million eligible Americans are fully
vaccinated that's just over 65 percent
of those who are eligible but less than
a third of eligible people have gotten
the boosters President Biden is
addressing the nation later today and
we're joined Now by his chief medical
advisor that's Dr Anthony fauci Dr fauci
as always it's good to have you here
you're coming at a very good time
because people are frightened and they
are confused and let's talk about the
the increase in the Omicron cases and
the Breakthrough with the boosters
that's what has people very very
concerned because you say get vaccinated
get boosted you're protected that does
not appear to be the case hopeless help
us understand what's happening to us
well when you're dealing with a virus a
variant like Omicron which has a really
a spectacular capability of spreading
from person to person we will be seeing
breakthrough infections of vaccinated
people as well as people who are
vaccinated and boosted that is going to
happen the issue is that people need to
understand that even with that the
likelihood of a vaccinated and boosted
person of getting seriously ill from the
infection is very very low it's the
unvaccinated people who are the most
vulnerable not only to getting infected
but to getting a serious outcome so I
understand how there could be some
confusion you tell people please get
vaccinated get boosted even if you do
get infected you are largely protected
against getting seriously ill and that's
the thing that people need to understand
they shouldn't throw up their hands and
say well if you can get infected even if
you're vaccinated why get vaccinated
there is a very big difference scale
between a vaccinated in an unvaccinated
person when they get infected with
regard to the consequences of that
infection
and so if you get if you if if God
forbid you do have one of these
breakthrough cases are you highly
contagious what needs to happen if you
do have a breakthrough case
well if you have a breakthrough case you
should be doing what everyone who gets
infected should do you should isolate
yourself for a period of time if you do
get sick and you get some symptoms you
should notify your health care provider
and see what the best thing to do is but
as I mentioned the likelihood of getting
significantly ill is going to be very
low so what it would likely be is that
you'd have to just isolate yourself for
a while it's really very important Gail
for people to get that point that you're
going to be reading about breakthrough
infections because this virus is
extremely good at transmitting from
person to person but vaccination and
boosting clearly is the answer to
protecting yourself from infection but
even if you do get infected protecting
yourself from severe disease
but Dr fauci when it comes to those
vaccinated and boosted people who get a
breakthrough I know they're less likely
to be hospitalized are they also less
likely to transmit it in particular to
other people in their family who are
also vaccinated and boosted can you say
anything reassuring about those
maximally protected households
we have a lot of data with regard to
Delta and we know that if you have a
breakthrough infection with Delta and
you're vaccinated versus unvaccinated
although you have a high level of virus
initially in your nasopharynx it drops
rather dramatically and quickly when
you're vaccinated which means you would
diminish the time frame with which
you're infected to someone else so that
you would not be endangering someone
else there will be a period when you
will be able to transmit the virus and
that's the reason why when we talk about
the importance of a comprehensive
approach not only getting vaccinated
getting boosted but when you're out in
congregate settings in situations where
you don't know the vaccination status of
people it's very important to wear a
mask that is critical
but but Dr fauci that period of of being
infected or infectious meaning you can
spread it is really important to people
right now because so many people are
boosted but they're getting a
breakthrough case and now their holidays
are ruined right but what I hear you
saying is Maybe not maybe they can take
precautions with their family and feel
relatively safe yeah
yeah let's get this straight for people
because there is always this concern
that we're saying well you no one can
enjoy the holiday because of the Omicron
that's just not the case if you were
vaccinated you're boosted your family's
vaccinated and boosted you could feel
comfortable in the home setting of a
dinner or a gathering together with
family and friends who are in fact
vaccinated and boosted there's never a
zero risk in this world but the risk of
having an issue when you have the
conditions that I mentioned the
vaccinated and boosted in a home setting
not in a big 100 person indoor setting
that's an entirely different thing
that's quite risky no matter what the
circumstances but when you're talking
about what we all love to do with your
family I have my family my wife and my
children are in right now we're
vaccinated we're boosted I feel
perfectly comfortable in the home with
them having a dinner having a social
Gathering
okay Dr fauci speaking of comfortable I
want to ask you about that how we become
more comfortable with covet we hear you
okay so Omicron is highly transmissible
and if you're vaccinated it's not as
severe it's mild from what we hear and
if you're unvaccinated results can be
different but could Omicron and these
other variants spread to the point where
we have population immunity and we begin
to live with this long term like the
common cold or flu
that's entirely conceivable and and
likely as a matter of fact we are not
going to be in a situation of this
degree of intensity indefinitely for
sure and what we're hoping that when we
get through this Omicron wave that we
will have enough people vaccinated and
or having been infected and recovered
well that there will be a degree of
immunity in the community such that you
don't have a situation where it's
dominating your life with a level of
infection and control is very low we
hope we get there soon in our own
country we first got to get the 50
million or so people who have are
eligible to be vaccinated who've not
gotten vaccinated that is critical if
you want to keep the level of spread in
the country as low as possible which
would get us back to some degree of
normality you've got to get those
unvaccinated people vaccinated not only
for their own protection because you
don't want them to get sick
yeah they're done those people Dr fauci
they're not listening I'm I'm I'm trying
to you know be very uh charitable yeah
realistic but they're not listening
before you go for um to uh for your uh
Christmas holiday
how soon how far Advanced should you get
tested before you go Christmas is
Saturday should you be tested on
Wednesday Thursday Friday when should
you get that last test before you go
yeah I mean if it should probably be
within one to two days now that we have
a greater and that's what the president
is going to talk about one or two days
before yeah
okay all right Dr fauci your birthday is
Christmas Eve but you're working 24 7. I
hope you at least get to have a piece of
cake at some point during the day thank
you
thank you so much looking good going on
closing on to 81. thank you sir we want
to hear your questions about this
pandemic and the Omicron variant you can
post them on our CBS morning's Instagram
Twitter or Facebook pages yep we have
those CBS newschief medical
correspondent Dr John lapuk will answer
some of them this Thursday on CBS
Morning